An alarming amounts of items in supermarkets
sold as reduced fat or healthy options are
actually concealing unbelievable amounts of
hidden calories, fats, sugars and salt.
Here's some of the worst, so called "healthy"
foods.
Prepared Salads
"Salads", surely not!
Many pre-prepared salads sold in supermarkets
and restaurants actually contain more calories
than a Big Mac.
Salad leaves, vegetables and fruits are incredibly
good for you, but it's the mayonnaise, salad
dressings and artificial flavourings that
pile on the pounds.
An average shop bought chicken salad with
dressing contains 730 calories, 48 grams of
fat and 1,280 milligrams of sodium.
Want a healthy salad?
Make your own and drizzle a bit of rapeseed
oil and lemon juice over it.
Reduced fat peanut butter
Believe it or not, you're much better off
eating normal peanut butter than the reduced
fat variety.
Reduced fat peanut butter and regular peanut
butter contain exactly the same amount of
calories.
However reduced fat peanut butter contains
a shedload of added sugar to supplement the
reduced fat.
Sugar is much worse for you than natural peanut
fats.
To produce reduced fat peanut butter, the
peanuts are stripped of all their natural
oils.
Peanut oils are fatty, but they contain good
monounsaturated fats, which actually have
many health benefits such as reduced cholesterol
levels, lower risk of heart disease and general
weight loss.
Remove the fats and you remove all peanut
butter's health benefits.
Granola
Granola is a perfect example of bad food hiding
in healthy clothing.
You have to ask yourself, how can something
which tastes so good be healthy?
Granola is typically made with large amounts
of added sugar and fatty oils.
However oats are naturally good for you and
there are healthy brands of granola without
added sugar.
So check the ingredients before you buy.
Vitamin Water/Flavoured Water
Vitamin water may seem innocent on the surface
but it's basically hyped-up sugared water.
A bottle of Glaceau vitamin water contains
8 teaspoons of sugar, cleverly disguised on
the label as "crystalline fructose", which
is basically a form of sugar.
It also contains excessive amounts of citric
acid which can be unhealthy in large quantities
and causes erosion of the teeth.
Want a vitamin water that's really good for
you?
Squeeze a lemon into a glass of water.
Lemons contain all the vitamins of vitamin
water, without the added sugar.
Energy Bars/Cereal Bars
Energy bars are packed full of sugar.
Some energy bars actually contain more sugar
than a can of cola and others are almost one
third fat.
Sure energy bars will provide you with quick
energy, because that's what sugar does, but
it will very quickly wear off and leave you
feeling more lethargic than you did before.
Guess what, your body can only use so much
sugar at once, the rest of it is turned into
fatty acids and stored inside your body, piling
on the pounds.
When you eat an energy bar, that's exactly
what happens to the majority of the sugars.
Multigrain Foods
Don't mistake multigrain for whole grain,
there's a very distinct difference.
Wholegrain means the food contains all parts
of the grain, whereas multigrain means the
food contains different types of grain, although
none of them has to be wholegrain.
Wholegrain foods are packed full of healthy
nutrients and fibre.
Whereas multigrain foods don't necessarily
contain any healthy grains whatsoever.
Smoothies
In small amounts, pure fruit smoothies are
very good for you.
But many contain large amounts of added sugar,
ice cream or sherbet.
Even pure fruit smoothies are bad for you
in large amounts.
Fruits contain lots of natural sugars, which
are much better for you than refined sugar,
but even natural fruit sugars will put weight
on you, if you eat enough of them.
Some smoothies served at smoothie bars clock
in at over 500 calories.
However smoothies contain numerous health
benefits because of all the beneficial vitamins
and minerals in fruit.
Make your own smoothies using pure fruit and
water and stick to one small glass a day to
keep the weight off, whilst soaking up all
the benefits.
Fat Free/Zero Calories
Fat free versions of foods may seem great
at first glance, but you're actually better
off eating the full fat variant.
Don't mistake "fat free" for calorie free,
fat free foods often contain more calories
than regular foods.
When you remove the fat from food you also
remove most of the taste.
So to counter that, food manufacturers replace
the fat with sugars, sweeteners, thickeners
and salt.
These can all be much worse for you than fat.
You see, it's not fat that's the problem,
it's the type of fat.
There are two types of unhealthy fats: saturated
fats and trans fats.
Similarly there are two types of healthy fats:
monounsaturated fats and polyunsaturated fats.
Fat free foods are stripped of any healthy
fats they may have had and replaced with unhealthy
sugars and salts.
Diet Soda/Artificial Sweeteners
Studies at the University of Texas Health
Science Center have shown that the more diet
soda a person drinks, the greater their chance
of becoming overweight.
Diet sodas are packed full of artificial sweeteners
which disrupt the body's natural ability to
control calorie intake.
The most commonly used are aspartame, cyclamate,
saccharin, acesulfame-k and sucralose.
The list of negative effects afflicted from
artificial sweeteners is endless.
It has been strongly linked to depression.
Individuals who drink diet soda are 30% more
likely to be diagnosed with depression in
their lifetimes.
Artificial sweeteners, greatly increase the
risk of preterm delivery amongst pregnant
women.
But scariest of all, regular consumption of
diet soda increases your risk of type II diabetes
by 67%.
So next time you have a sugar craving, you're
much better off satisfying it with regular,
full-fat soda.
The same applies to tea and coffee, it's actually
better for you to sweeten your drinks with
sugar than artificial sweeteners.
Sushi
Most sushi is made with white rice, but contains
very small amounts of the good stuff, A.K.A.
fish.
White rice is high-glycemic food.
High-glycemic foods promote a rapid increase
in blood sugar and insulin levels, which is
followed by a very rapid drop in both.
This leads to a greatly increased appetite
which makes you crave junk food.
Whilst sushi is not that unhealthy in a direct
sense it can easily lead to over eating.
However some sushis do contain copious amounts
of added salt.
Dried Fruit
Surely dried fruit is good for you, after
all it's just fruit.
Think again.
Fruit is mostly water, remove the water and
you're left with pure sugar.
This small amount of sugar isn't so bad when
you consume whole fruits, but when you eat
dried fruit you're eating a lot more sugar
per portion.
A small handful of raisins contains 22 grams
of sugar.